[Musik]
so also gefeiert zum tag der offenen tür
so macht die grundausbildung in der
kaserne alles klar bis in die kaserne
weiterreden wir sind in berlin
die grundausbildung beginnt auch jetzt
[Musik]
hallo hallo nutzt
oberstleutnant willi genau fast 100
punkte aber sie müssen mich heute fit
machen ich erkläre ihnen kurze situation
ich bin damals ausgemustert worden
tatsächlich ich fühle mich gedemütigt
von diesem land und ich möchte heute
beweisen das ich mehr bin der immer noch
bereit ist ein zu stehen für dieses land
tolle einstellung das kriegen wir hin
die patellasehne ist ein bisschen über
den tatsächlich hatte probleme weil ich
vom musical ja ein bisschen norden
getanzt wir haben hier wir haben hier
fähige ärzte ja ist also also das heißt
wenn was passiert ist rechner arzt oder
wenn was passiert ist ein arzt die sehne
im notfall weg damit ich habe ja noch
eine andere
hallo oberleutnant martin martin darf
mich nicht gerne ja schön dich
kennenzulernen ebenso vorbereitet haben
wir jetzt erstmal ein vertrag damit auch
ambitionen musst das ist der vertrag
oder war ja auch sehr gerne mal
durchlesen es ist nicht euer herz die
verpflichtung gilt ab sofort ich bin mit
allem einverstanden mit allem korrekt
das kenne ich eigentlich so beim militär
dass man ordentlich was zu sauf kriegt
vorher und so willenlos ist dass man
unterschreibt aber er findet erst mal
nicht starten rennen sich die erste
große enttäuschung aber
das war ein fehler so anziehen
ich fühle mich dass ich jetzt irgendwie
auch keiner schon mal sie ist auch
besser aus dann geht's los oder labors
weiß zwar nicht was geht los
was ist ihr auftrag was genau machen sie
hier ich bin zum tag der offenen tür
eigentlich nur hier und wollte so ein
bisschen
bisschen die sachen so in erfahrung
bringen dann seitdem man das aber auch
richtig machen ja dann zeige ich ihnen
jetzt mal direkt wie man es richtig
macht weil sowas will ich nicht mehr
sehen okay sie haben pflanzen auf dem
kopf das absicht
nach vorne
und nahm bogen wie möglich ist ein
bisschen auf meine knie aufpassen gibt's
ja nicht weiter
ohne geräusche
bisschen hier tatsächlich oft
während lux durch den waltrop bin ich
beim tag der bundeswehr in warendorf und
warte auf die
bundesverteidigungsministerium noch ist
die nirgendwo zu sehen also alles wie
immer na dann was ich erst mal ein paar
soldaten strammstehen sorgen
hallo
[Musik]
und sagen sie nicht mit modernen
flugzeuge also
da ist jetzt gerade der sohn von frau
lambrecht mit
sicherheit nicht wer soll denn hier
beeindruckt werden das eigene land oder
die potenziellen gegner
also ich denke mal dass unsere
bevölkerung die gelegenheit bekommt zu
sehen was kann diese bundeswehr haben
eigentlich alles leisten hier können wir
zeigen hier im grunde genommen dass wir
menschen wie alle anderen eben hier kann
man auch mal munition mitgehen lassen
ohne
munition haben wir ja hier leider nicht
die alle geglaubt
haben geklaut
[Musik]
parole
november
juli unten bleiben unten bleiben unten
raimund mehr und
immer noch unten und mir ja klar und es
geht mir auf die knie immer nach unten
folgendes lage ja wir alle posten oder 1
der asv gruppe sichern vorfeld alles
klar nachbarn links 200 umschlag 2 1 nv
gvg rechte grenze zur ein
alleinstehender grüner baum fernglas weg
erst zuhören
natürliches raum umschlag gruppe 2 nv
gvg verstanden verstanden kein wort
kann ich mal die waffe haben nein jetzt
sage ja kritiker das 100 milliarden und
tropfen auf den heißen stein sind ja
aber nebenbei neben den 100 milliarden
haben wir ja auch noch 50,4 milliarden
einzelplan 14 das militär aber so
ob das reicht wird
schauen sie sich mal unsere brücken
haben in unserem land wir brauchen
infrastruktur da können wir noch nicht
waren panzer drüberfahren über die
leverkusener brücke jedenfalls nicht
einmal schon
hier 36 der bundesrat das geht aber
nicht das original das ist an sich so
bisher steht schon das original ist nur
mit technik versagt also kann ich
wirklich schießen ja nur eine patrone
also wie die echte g36 können nicht
wirklich
möglich machen den musste ich machen und
jetzt sehen sie in roten punkt klar na
dann grün sein ab
geht nicht weil nichts ist doch eine
echte geseker
funktioniert nicht wir machen die
sicherung rasso deshalb
vorher erlaubnis
hat reicht so
gute leistung gezeigt haben manchmal das
bild dann holt das bild run männer was
sehen wir da wo unsere getroffen einmal
die mitte öfter auf die neuen hefte auf
die acht ja einmal hat sich das bild der
bundeswehr denn verändert in den letzten
jahren jetzt gerade auch durch die
ukraine definitiv
also die resonanz ist natürlich ich sag
mal schon ein bisschen umgeschwenkt von
anti bundeswehr zu pro bundeswehr wenn
man sie sich viele besucher wie man
sieht
die resonanz ist sehr starke ganz viele
bewerber zahlen die man danach eignung
leistung und befähigung halt versucht in
die streitkräfte einzubinden durch
einstellung in die bundeswehr sowie war
ansatzweise heute morgen schon gesagt
der mensch
wir holen uns den an van der vorst ja
was heißt ansatzweise also ich finde ich
hab das ja schon ziemlich gut
durchgezogen die händler
es ist luft nach oben bei mir sind
inzwischen zwei außergewöhnliche dinge
passiert soldaten setzten sich auf hunde
und noch viel unglaublicher mann darf
christine lambrecht etwas fragen gibt
einen interessenten für fragen der herr
mit dem hellblauen hemd bitte der herr
im blauen poloshirt bitte und der herr
im schwarzen hemd bitte noch letzte
frage
ist unfassbar ich bedanke mich recht
herzlich mit dem verständnis aufgrund
der kürze der zeit dass wir jetzt leider
verlassen müssen alles gute für sie frau
ministerin schönen tag ach die hat mich
wahrscheinlich nur übersehen oder kommt
sie ja auch schon zum exklusiv
lambrecht sie sind ja seit dezember im
amt konnten sie sich heute einen ersten
eindruck von der bundeswehr machen echt
schade dass lamprechts presseoffizier
nichts über die reichweite von
mikrofonen
beinahe eine private frage können sie
mich später mit dem heli nach köln
mitnehmen
hallo das ist die automatische and card
von fabian köster leider bin ich gerade
bei einer veranstaltung der fdp ihr
könnt euch aber hier oder hier gerne ein
weiteres video angucken und den kanal
abonnieren vielen dank
dann kannst das selbermachen entsorgt du
weißt du ich bin bei der fdp wird es
neben der kamera ich bin bei der fdp
[Musik]
vielen dank